okay for people joining this live stream
some of you may have been at the
previous live stream about pdes this is
a very different live stream about code
assistance
and we are looking at brenton's screen
here
and we're going to hear about progress
in
uh code assistance yeah so
i think we're going to try to split this
up between john talking and then
and then me talking um i don't know if
john wants to share his screening
you know if we need to bother but um
yeah so the first thing was about front
end
not issues but you know progress that so
john do you want to say something about
this what is this
um okay so the uh um
uh sorry i'm readjusting things on my
screen so i can see what we're actually
looking at
um the uh um so here's the problem that
we need to solve
um uh we need to have
some way to map from
uh brenton's uh representation of the
syntax tree
to the representation of the syntax tree
that
is in the notebook um uh
and we need this so that we can do
things like you know brenton wants to
tag a particular you know
a particular bit of syntax as needing
correction
or you know should be highlighted in
some way or something like that
well you need to tell the front end what
thing to tag right
um so where does where does brenton's
abstract syntax tree live
it's not in it's in it's in memory
somehow in some representation go ahead
explain that
well i mean brenton could probably
explain better than
than i could but i i i started by
looking at this stuff
super loud john i don't know why
i think he's about the same volume as
you okay fine
i'll whisper um don't worry about it
so the um i
i i started by looking at what britain
has generated
uh generating from the uh uh uh
in the code parser stuff that's on
github um and
a code parser has uh you know along with
parsing strings they can parse boxes
um and uh yeah
if if you could just throw up an example
of that real quick
that would be really good um
and so um the uh
uh i mean basically he is you know
breaking out things into the individual
components one of the things i noticed
was that
curious little association there which
is basically a part spec for each node
right yeah um and
i thought well britain already has this
information
maybe i can make this information work
to map back into the front end
okay so i've got a question here i mean
the design of this container node and
all this kind of thing have we ever
reviewed this we haven't have we yet
um i mean i've brought it up no i mean
there's nothing been
finalized but i think modulo
re you know names of things the
structure
is pretty much correct yeah where does
this
live are you saying the
what your previous question or are you
saying the code yeah my previous
question
you know this is a kernel thing um it's
not
there's native code but you know you can
just think of these are just normal
these are mathematica expressions that
live you know in memory
okay okay and they're created on the fly
or what
yeah um it's not they read from you know
the file or the string but they're
they're they're separated from that
they're not you know
intrinsically related to anything to do
with where you know
the bytes on the disk or anything like
that um
aft after the fact so first of all
i think it was about yeah i was just
gonna i was just wondering i mean
is there sort of a fundamental
difference in what this is representing
to like
the box language or is this just sort of
a more convenient
there are a couple different key
differences one
is um well yeah i don't feel like typing
right now but
so i keep track of what i call implicit
tokens
where you know implicit times being the
big thing
where you know i might have you might
have that in the front end
and it will tell you
that there's no box for the
multiplication but in terms of the
actual sort of syntax tree there is a
multiplication
yeah um i'm trying to like sorry
figure stuff out there's something to do
with white space
going on i don't really understand yeah
anyway um
[Music]
forget i just showed that but the
the idea is that you have
you know you keep track of things like
these implicit tokens
and times being the big thing um nulls
that are after semicolons and stuff like
that and
the stuff on either side of span
operators you know stuff like that
they're all implicit but they're very
very very convenient to keep track of as
if they did
the cost to keeping track of those in
the box language would not be high it's
just that the box language hasn't
traditionally done that
well you know it depends on
how you're keeping track of them um
i mean there are some boxes which are
created
and destroyed at high speed as you're
typing
um uh if you chose to for example keep
track of them by assigning uuids to them
you know the cost of generating id every
time would be high
uh or higher than we would be
comfortable with okay question for all
of this this
we have several places where where we
have the analog of abstract syntax trees
we have that in text structure
we have that in chris cooley's project
to do um
um abstract syntax trees for external
languages and so on what
consistency do we have between these
these different forms
currently absolutely none i suspect this
looks like a fairly general version of
these
yeah like you know if we move metadata
to the front
or the back i mean you know these things
i understand i understand but we have to
make decisions right so one thing we
need to do
is inventory all these places where we
have abstract syntax trees
and just once and for all decide what
our standard form for an abstract syntax
tree should be
and the p people i guess it's tony
schundler who's working on
on um the trees project should also be
part of that
so one one issue though is that i think
that
okay fundamentally the quotes the
abstract syntax tree of the actual
code is just the expression of the code
right and like you put an activate
around it or something like that
no no no no no right it says these
contain other information is the point
right these are not just abstraction
these are not just
abstract syntax trees and they contain
other stuff that depends on the project
and so i think it's you know
i'm not sure these can all be lumped
together like that it's important
when we're talking about the apps i mean
yes we can talk about full forms or you
know
just the actual x the plus expert but
with what i'm doing it's important to
maintain
this level of you know saying call node
and leaf nodes still so
right how it was typed right i mean you
care about the actual
right this is what i mean though is that
i think what
what you care about is you know
i i would argue that in most cases the
abstract syntax tree
is just a representation of like you
know
this is the abstract syntax tree what
what brenton is doing here is not the
abstract syntax tree
well this this is no it isn't it's got
the source positions and things in it
well i mean it came i mean that doesn't
mean it's not abstract i mean this has
been abstracted
in a sense from you know from this has
the same structure
as if i you know these both have
the same structure i mean you know if
you ignore the metadata
you know yeah if you ignore the metadata
but there is meditator here which is
good
okay listen listen action from this
let's get a summit meeting about this
representation
let's get the people involved with the
trees project and these other various
places where we
need similar kinds of things that
represent both the surface form of an
expression
and its structure okay i mean to me what
you've got here looks pretty reasonable
but i think we just need to decide how
we're standardizing it
okay because what you've got there is
very very similar to the text structure
system but not quite the same so let's
get it standardized so that we can do
the same thing
you see that thing where you give source
that's exactly like a verb phrase
or something in a piece of uh natural
language processing
right would have exactly that same thing
of the you know it needs to know where
the source was for it etc
right you go get what i'm saying and
we've already got something very much
like this like
jerome has something very much like this
so okay
can somebody who is who is dealing with
yeah yeah
yeah i can get that scheduled okay all
right let's move on here
so box extract and box read
are going from the box form to this form
is that right
uh so the idea is so box read is
very similar to notebook read uh
but it has a few more options and
it it's never going to give you anything
like a wrapping cell expression or
something like that
um but the the the point of box read
is to give you something that uh you
know like in in brenton's case
uh you know to give you a set of boxes
that you can analyze and generate
part information from and then you can
pass that part information to box
extract um and or
box extract i should say um and
uh and then uh
so any parts that you pass the box
extract
will give you box objects once you have
box objects
now you're back in the front end world
and now you can do things like
you know add uh annotations or
you know uh you know you know add
squiggly underlines
or attach cells or something like that
okay i mean i i i don't know if you're
looking at this on your screen or not
it's in cvs so you you
could look at the docs on your screen if
you wanted to could you see them please
brenton could you bring them up
or well let me share um
yeah yeah i already have them on screen
sorry yep
okay um let me just
hide something here before i share my
screen okay
um is my volume better by the way yes
but go ahead and check
okay um
so i recognize we might not have
i mean you know i'm not looking for a an
absolutely final uh
pass on this but i want to make sure
that you know the general
concepts are not objectionable in any
way
so box read can take a cell object or a
box object
and it will return an association with
the actual boxes like you get from
notebook read
and a hash now the boxes
might be modified in a couple different
ways under my design here
uh there might be some stripping of the
boxes so for example
um the uh
when you do shift enter uh to send
you know you know a box expression to
the kernel to be evaluated
uh it actually strips uh it strips white
space
comments uh non-semantic style boxes
non-semantic
white space and so on um why is this
called box read rather than box import
well i don't know whether but but look
it boxes well and
it it's it's parallel to notebook read
um
notebook doesn't return an association
with hashes in it and things
show the notebook read documentation
yeah and a book read returns yeah
something like this
or you know it can return boxes
depending on what your selection is
um i would argue
that the default should be to return
just the boxes object
from box read and to have a second
argument which gives
lets you get that full association so
so and let me let me explain the reason
for the hash uh
the reason for the hash so this is an
internal crypto hash we compute them all
the time they're very
cheap and easy to compute uh and the
idea is that
you know you're gonna call uh like in
brenton's loop you know brenton
would call box read and then he's gonna
do some processing on it
that processing might take time during
that time
it is possible that the user or some
program you know might go and modify the
notebook i get it i understand i
understand why you want to hash that
i'm just talking about the design here
and so then you just feed that hash
if you want to fail on a mismatch
but then then why not have a wrapper
around the boxes
that is called box hash or something or
you know
that is just a rapper symbolic wrapper
to the boxes when returned
that has this hash information in it um
i thought this would be more in line
with the sort of
design you'd be interested in i'm not uh
so you're suggesting
um
box hash of um
of boxes um
hash something like that yeah i'm sure
you're right the name box hash isn't
probably quite right but i mean
you know um
box hashing or something i mean if you
just type that in box hashing
um because hash would suggest an actual
action but this is
right yeah this is just saying this is a
wrapper that you could put anywhere
um i i don't know if this is right but i
don't think what you have is quite right
because it doesn't it's not parallel to
an open creed
i don't think we want to get too far
into this i mean
well it like i said i don't feel like i
need
all the details worked out but uh but
this is this is a direction that we can
move on if we know the general direction
is going to be fine
i think it's fine but i would recommend
putting the symbolic wrapper like box
hashing around the boxes that come back
okay um and uh
otherwise i yeah because that way you
can leave that in the notebook you can
do all kinds of things with it
it's not uh and so where
this would be like some summary blob
sort of type set into some summary blob
you're thinking
probably yeah i mean how would it be
types that
the boxes would be yeah something like
that
i mean when would you see this
you'll see it when you're doing very
internal operations yeah i mean i mean
this is
i mean i wouldn't know there may be some
other box operations like this that we
would add but
it would be yeah it's going to be very
low level operations
right and i mean i would say the hash
could just be some something which is
some annotation around the expression
that has a little blue
thing around it with a little thing that
says you know hash or something i don't
know
i don't think it needs to be i don't
think that's the most important thing
because i think that this will be seen
by people doing
you know programming type stuff yes um
that's definitely true so i mean as a
convenience it could just be a little
thing with a little footnote for the
hash
but this seems okay to me uh and then
the other thing just to be clear
but by the way i don't think you would
use me if if you are passing
you know non-default values into here
then you would want to match them on
this side because you know the
the part spec is going to change based
on your stripping
and why don't you why don't you have
that being the symbolic wrapper that you
return for the boxes
why don't you have box read return
something with a symbolic wrapper that
contains the box
okay so here's maybe you're not
understanding this
this isn't what you're going to feed
back to box extract
why not this is what you're going to
process
to get the position specs that you want
yeah okay and then what are you gonna
feedback
how would you check the heck this is a
standard extract style position spec
no i understand that but when you feed
it back the obj for box extra obj is the
same
yeah but needs to have the hash right
box hashing
needs to have the hash otherwise it
couldn't do a check hash
yeah so i yeah yeah so uh
uh so something like that but
um but the point being though is that
you're going to have processed
this in some way to create this
let's not get stuck on this let's do a
separate discussion about this the
the general direction looks fine but i'm
just suggesting if you're going to have
to have agreement between what box read
reads and what box extract extracts from
why don't you have a symbolic wrapper
that contains the box stripping
information so you don't have to
so you can just say it's automatic in
box extract and it doesn't and it gets
carried along
in the object if i did notice something
i mean that's my only suggestion
okay all right let's go back to brunton
oh yep i'll share my screen again
so that's not the only obstacle to
getting the user interface up and
running but it's the one that prevents
getting even a prototype user interface
up and running
so just implement those things i mean
they look fast yes
uh and then there will be further stuff
we'll
talk about in the future about uh by the
way if you if you want to have those
be in an in a you know in an internal
context in a code assistance context or
something like that then just go right
ahead with the design
i i i i well i think they'll actually be
useful for
uh other people internally and probably
some people externally too all right
look at this
then we should clean the designs yeah
okay let's keep going
i want to talk about the code formatter
okay
oh yeah so i mean was that it for you
john yes
okay okay yeah so that that's good okay
hurry up yes code formatter please
let's see some stuff yeah so what i've
been doing
is palette and line breaking um
i've been working with this sample file
llbm.m
and so
opening that up in the package editor so
it's going to be useful to have a
palette i think
for formatting code in you know in
notebooks
so i've simply been adding to
it as i see fit it has not been designed
reviewed or anything like that
yet but there is a ticket open to
you know have it reviewed and designed
and graphic designed and everything but
mainly people are just going to want to
format current cell
and format current notebook so you know
you have this open
i don't agree with the fact that we want
a palette there i think in the case of a
of the package editor we just have that
be in the toolbar but it doesn't matter
i want to see the functionality oh yes
that is a very good point yes
so you know you you can click inside of
any cell
okay all right i just want to see yeah i
want to see the thing actually run on
some
non-trivial piece of code
you know bigger chunks here yeah so
what is it doing well so i mean can you
see this can you see the text changing
when i click on it
so i'll click on it now and you see i
can see it changing but i i mean
i don't know what it's doing i mean we
discussed all these airiness parameters
and all that kind of thing
where am i seeing all of that stuff yeah
so um
at least interactively through a palette
it will be hard to control these
parameters
um you know okay just show me there's
more thinking
but at least programmatically i will now
i can move to just showing these
parameters
um being used programmatically though
okay all right fine
so just select a cell sorry
select a cell let's see it run i mean
select a cell there
yep so i mean it just needs the cursor
is just in the cell so that's sufficient
and then i click on that
and then it re you know it adds new
lines and it adds you know all that okay
so so now
okay so now what happens if you change
the airiness
increase the airiness well i is this
really non-typical code this is not
co okay not now press format current i'm
not sure if this will
yeah okay yep good so uh maximal
airiness
okay okay all right reduce the airiness
now
a bit so selecting the cell again um
i i don't know where the inflection okay
okay
but so you know a little bit less here
that's good this is what we wanted for
the airiness thing now now
presumably for a cell the airiness could
be done interactively yes the area is we
could just move a slider and it can
change it
yes that's what i'm nervous about
why well that's what we're going to have
reading and notebook
writing but we've got to have that work
right so so whatever makes you nervous
has got to be resolved
yes i agree yes
so what is it exactly that is well no i
just mean dynamics and notebook reading
okay you know what we gotta actually
make it work so i don't care how nervous
you are can you show it can you demo it
or not no it's not i don't have it even
no not through the palette no okay so
john
john yeah yeah is there anything that
makes you nervous about this
uh for smallish cells
um it's definitely
buildable without a huge amount of
effort i mean they're going to be
performance problems once you
get a certain size of course that's fine
and we can have some heuristics
for making it not interactive at that
point just like we do for manipulates we
just move it
and then you know we don't have
continuous action you know above some
size don't have continuous action
yeah yeah okay yeah i mean so yeah and
we can
okay all right okay so re-parse
boxes before formatting what does that
mean what is that oh yeah i mean
wherever
this will live but the idea is that
people love
for some reason people love going into
unformatting cells
and hand changing this stuff and
sometimes that results in invalid
you know box structures okay i get it
okay enough said enough said
okay so yeah yeah okay all right so
what we've discussed previously is
the ability to i mean remind me because
it's been two months since we met
remind me what we had concluded about
the um
uh let's see about how things like
airiness
we had another parameter in addition to
airiness what was it well
line width is you know the next big one
which i can which i was going which i'm
going to show
okay but but what is what do we think
the uses of these are going to be so
basically it's you take a piece of code
and it has to be dead easy to increase
the airiness
right and and presumably in a notebook
other than
this pure you know in a regular notebook
you should
you're able to do this also with just
pure things which have line wrapping
right
oh yeah yeah i'm i mean i picked the
package editor but i mean anything
yeah okay so so how about
right but but let's see it from a
notebook that isn't
a notebook with other code in it if i
need to send you a notebook with codec
oh no go to the function repository
um i mean i'm not logged i don't know
how what do you mean you don't know how
i mean i haven't been which what is the
just google wolfram function repository
i never remember what the address is
that's what i always do
okay resources will from cloud yep fine
um okay now go to i don't know multi-way
system
type it in the search
okay now get the first one
now say source notebook
okay now you're gonna have a big blob of
code
is i'm not sure what's well just open it
no the open dialogue isn't oh
you're you're running into a bug here
you may have to
quit and restart you might have to force
quit even um
um do could i continue or what
no i want to see this i really want to
see this yeah
can you not open it by pressing on the
file even if the open dialog doesn't
work
you might be able to drag it to the icon
on the dock but yeah
so what should you do now
should you just try it again okay yeah
it came up
okay dandy all right let's go go
scroll down a bit okay these are pretty
small
scroll down there's probably some bigger
pieces later on
maybe not
okay we'll just pick some pixels oh
there you go all right now oh sorry no
no that's more
okay there's a piece there's a piece
there yeah it fits on the
screen so yeah the cursor is in the cell
so i'm going to click
format currents i think everything will
load fine yep okay cool yep okay
so yeah that's now been that's now been
formatted
okay according to your formatting
conditions okay as
code right
has been formatted as if it were in a
code cell or is it fine that it's not in
code cell
i mean there's no distinction between
code cell input cell yeah i mean the
they're they're forming
so these commas that sit on their own
lines are pretty weird
yeah which okay so what
so the whole thing is there might have
been a new line
in the original cell that's it don't
think so
i don't think so well i mean i'd have to
go and check i'd have to i don't think
so i wouldn't expect the code was
written that way
okay so increase the airiness for this
for a second
yeah all the way or no no not all the
way not all the way
it's gonna look crazy all the way so i'm
gonna reformat now
kind of even looks better kind of
yeah it does look better okay so now
now increase the airiness even further
okay so yeah
cursor is in there i don't know if
there's another inflection point before
all the way but i won't it's not going
well
why would that be an inflection point in
other words isn't it continuously
changing up the airiness parameter
well i mean the variables change i mean
it's this is a slider but it's it's only
happening at like 0.25
you know kind of increment kind of
things why
isn't isn't it a continuously varying
you know waiting function
well i mean you know new lines either
get added or they don't i mean this
isn't really a continuous
thing i understand that but but there's
probably some heuristic that says at
this airiness level i start making this
formatting decision
yeah right yeah i i i think stephen
maybe you're
thinking as if you were globally
optimizing to fit this
in 20 lines and 23 lies and 26 lines i
i don't think that's the way brenton's
code works no it's not what it's doing
okay go to full airiness yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
uh so cursor's in there reformat and
yep okay so i don't think this area is
i don't think this slider is quite right
i mean i think this is interesting
right i don't think it's quite right yet
the the airiness you had below this was
was obviously more sensible for this but
i i think okay ux wise what we need here
is something where i can just go select
a cell
and just in the toolbar change the
airiness
change the cell formatting see what i'm
saying
when there is a toolbar yeah well i know
but we're getting a toolbar right
that's that's part of what we're
planning for the next version right
um the uh i don't see how that's gonna
happen as part of 12 2
we are we are a very short time away
from
having to freeze and send 12 candidates
through
qa well is this going to be ready
brenton
yeah i mean the stuff that i'm showing
is shippable
yes except it's not interactive and what
you're going to need for the airiness
thing it's got to be dynamic right
so okay so listen here's what we're
going to do then
i mean also we need to know how this is
going to work in the cloud do we
understand that
i've been talking to yon i mean we're
we're thinking about yeah how this would
how this is going to apply
because yeah obviously you know this is
not using the same notebook
you know api and things are different
but um
underneath at the very end who's about
to say something's on here
no i i was about to speak up i i
i would be surprised if there are
fundamental challenges here i mean maybe
with the
maybe with the palette and the slider
but with the the round tripping and the
processing
i would be surprised that there were
fundamental challenges
well the main thing is the dynamic
timeout
you know and stuff okay okay yeah right
yeah
but that's pallet stuff that's not round
tripping you know through your
the cell contents okay listen so so
first point is
in the package editor you can absolutely
put the stuff in the toolbar
yeah okay and i guess noah could help
design figure out the ux for how that
works
um i suggest i mean go go to the
go to the uh package editor toolbar for
one second
okay i mean i i think it's pretty easy
just put it where you cursor is there
something about formatting and maybe we
have a thing that says
i don't know noah can try and figure it
out okay
um and obviously this thing about two
spaces four spaces six places all that
stuff
that is relevant for the package editor
is much less relevant for the notebook
itself
now my question is is it possible to fit
into version uh 12-2
a right-click um
menu item to change airiness um
yeah that would be i i mean it depends
on
you know does it just run or does it
bring up some kind of interface but
but adding stuff to context menu if if
the
you know if the implementation is there
straightforward
um actually just a quick quick
question about the two spaces for spaces
tab etc
um i mean arguably there could be sort
of a global setting for that i mean
this is not really for this meeting but
like uh you know there's something a lot
of editors do where oh when you press
tab it actually
types n spaces or something like that
yeah um
but uh i mean arguably there should at
some point be a global setting for that
and then this just inherits it
i thought there was some kind of setting
and the d is it
there's a setting for tab size but like
okay i have this issue because i insist
on setting my tab
size to be two so it's a two space tab
but then when anyone whenever anyone
else
opens something that i've been writing
now all of a sudden everything is
incredibly wide
because i'm putting lots of you know
small tabs but there
you understand so this is why people
like to have it converted to spaces so
at least it's consistent across
different you know people's computers
and so on
definitely don't want to get into tabs
versus spaces right now either
well yeah okay but holy war
yeah okay but but this is
this is not relevant for a notebook that
is
this is relevant for the for the uh
package editor but not for regular
notebooks right you were right yeah i
mean it's less relevant for notebooks
better to say relevant for code cells
and code style cells and not for input
style cells
sure yes yes well okay so then then
could we not fit some of this stuff into
the right click menu for now
and noah could perhaps try and design
something that goes in there
and and perhaps the right click menu
could literally be
i mean it would be nice to have a single
click
well i don't know if you if you say for
example an airiness where you can
reset where you have a a sticky airiness
setting
and that and by default you can go
somehow
and just go to a cell and and right
click and re-airify it
so to speak and i i should say
if this is good enough i don't want to
right click menu i want a keyboard
shortcut
well i i mean there's a question of you
know how how good will it be in practice
of course
but if well that would be great to have
a keyboard thing that says
you know just like you have command plus
for for increased size
a um uh yeah increase airiness decrease
airiness
that would be very useful
that's a good idea does adding does that
mean there would have to be a menu item
added necessarily
or not yeah um well
it's i mean a menu item is how you
discover the keyboard shortcuts
it's it's not a technical requirement
but it's a sort of a ux requirement
i think that's an excellent idea i think
it'll be really nice keys to but i mean
then we have to figure out
how you go in a decent number of steps
to different airiness levels
which i mean we obviously manage that
for size changes right i mean you can
make continuous size changes but yet we
have presets that make sense
i mean i would i would hope you know my
view
is that uh um and
maybe i'm an outlier but my view is you
know i want to play with airiness levels
once make a global decision and then i
just want to apply that setting over and
over and over again to all my code
i don't think you're going to want that
john i think you're going to i think
it's
it's what i do in other languages okay
okay well maybe it just works
okay fair enough well then then okay
i mean i mean because because what i
want to do when i type in code
is i don't want to think about
formatting i agree you know i don't want
to sit there saying
tab tab tab does it line up do i have to
line break here i don't want to have to
think about any of that stuff i just
type type type
all the way off you know you know uh you
know 400 characters in
and then and then line break it for me
yeah all right so listen some ux here
seems like this airiness parameter is
basically working
good work brenton um let's install it
i think the keyboard thing sounds good i
think a right-click menu is a good
uh intermediate step probably but
to be clear i'm not opposed to a right
click menu no i understand
i think i think the ice board it's more
useful it's much more useful but now
this question about stickiness to the
whole notebook i don't understand how
that will work ux wise
i mean then it's like the magnification
yeah well that's a good question
basically it should be like the
magnification setting what i would do
then is to have an extra
uh gear menu up by magnification and
have that be a setting in there
well you know uh on my to-do list was to
have you know a notebook properties
dialogue
i mean this makes sense in a notebook
properties dialogue
um yes
yes it does but i mean we could look the
notebook properties dialog could come
off a gear menu up there and we could
have this be the
inaugural member of the gear menu
yeah okay
brenton what else did you want to show
this is nice so yeah so john
said about he just wanted to have you
know say line breaking so i thought that
was a good segue to
what the next chunk of stuff i wanted to
show
go for it um open up the actual agenda
so then yeah so line breaking is in
and i need to actually
around things again so
line width can be adjusted to any
sensible value
meaning integer values greater than or
equal to
okay fine um and what you're not seeing
here
is so the very first version just did
the dumb thing of putting in
continuation markers
at the limits and just not thinking
about stuff but
i now have a the next version that kind
of does a sensible thing
of so by default 10 characters
before the line break would happen
you start looking at the characters and
start asking yeah okay
this is a good place to break i get it i
understand okay what does safety mean
yeah so that's the margin um so if i
said it i don't know
what is this for i don't understand why
haven't we had this for millions of
years this ability to just
break what what are we seeing that's
different here this is this is breaking
in
ordinary text not in a notebook
not with boxes is that right these are
strings yeah
i see so this is the line breaker that
just takes strings
and it's parsing the string and figuring
out how to where to line break it
i mean it's the four yeah yeah i mean
it's yeah yeah i mean you know
internally so so let me understand that
do we have somebody from the cloud team
here
because they've had a line breaker that
works on
essentially string like representations
of expressions right
i don't think anyone from the clouds
here no that's a
shame but you don't know that fact right
benton
i know that they had something yeah um
well have you talked to them because you
need to
because either they should be using your
thing or your thing should be using
their thing
yes yes um hey so
can can you make sure you let's see
who's who's pm'ing here
yeah i can make sure they know about
this okay
that's nice all right let's keep going
so
yeah um so airiness
combined you know you can have the two
these are just
for example chunks of code that i have
to
increase airiness and you know the line
width
you can change but you'll notice here
you know there are not
continuation markers at the end of every
line um
the line breaking is being done you know
semi-intelligently
so um that's that if no one else has
although the example on screen has a
curious line break in a comment
there well i mean but you said yeah
well that's not optimal yes that's
correct
i mean that's just that's just a little
bug yeah that's a little bug
that down okay so now this thing here
where you say code format we have a
function called code format
is that actually a useful function at
least it could be in the function
repository if nothing else
well it it's hard because it depends on
the parser
i mean it there's a lot of dependency
behind this
so what well so the parser has native
code in it i mean
they can't really live in the function
repository no but just documentation
good i mean it can be something which is
based on some internal
context but it can be exposed to users
through the function repository i don't
think we want
a this doesn't seem like a function well
cooked enough to be as
a standard system function yeah no i
mean it's it's in its own context right
now yeah
right but i'm suggesting that it is a
function that will be useful to expose
where the definition of the function
repository could just be code format
equals
back tick internal back tick blah blah
blah blah blah blah whatever
yeah i mean if that's a thing that is we
that we watch
yeah that's the thing because it
provides a documentation hook
yeah okay yep
so yeah so that's nice that's nice okay
quickly if people care what are people's
opinions about
line actual default line widths um email
us do these days
so um yeah so the front end breaks it uh
actually i think it might be 72 instead
of 70.
actually i think that's correct yeah and
and and the reason for that
is because uh of concern when you send
it through
an email program that you might end up
with
uh a line break that changes the
semantics
yep exactly i would do 72 characters
yeah i mean it's it's kind of
neanderthal and
hopefully some decade we can increase
that but for now i would do 72.
yeah i mean that i mean perfectly doable
yep okay
next item implicit times and line
continuation so
interesting thing running into i think
this just captures the issue um
those are not the same expressions
and i don't know if there's anything to
do here
but i just thought it was maybe this is
just a general interest item
but the formatter
this is one case de-implicify times
yeah yeah so this is the one case where
the formatter is doing something like
that
sounds like a good thing to me yeah oh i
mean yeah yeah sure
um i mean and that's basic i i think
that's pretty much all that can be done
um wherever yeah right yeah
so that's basically the uh
the the plain text version of the front
ends uh
auto times feature yep why does it need
the backslash
well here i mean this is not optimal i
mean obviously inside of parentheses you
don't need it but
um if it were if these were topics i get
it i get it i get it i get that's enough
okay so basically this is i think this
is uncontroversial
you de-implicify the implicit times
so yeah i i guess started the project
hoping
that i could get away with a clean you
know this is like the one thing
this is the one place that i have to do
something like that that won't be the
only place
there'll be others there'll be some with
numbers i suspect as well
um well inserting spaces to separate
things out is completely fine you know
which i do
um to maintain yeah separation between
tokens of
you know underscores and stuff like that
um but
you know this is something that's
non-white space that i'm interested in
it's life minifire let's look at the
minifire
what is the minifire so yeah so i was
talking to yon in the cloud
group um as kind of a result of
this formatting stuff an easy kind of
side effect
is having a code minifier which
i mean this may or may not be useful for
anyone but
javascript frameworks have are have
minifiers for when they want to send
plain text
over the network to minimize bandwidth
i'm well aware i'm well aware of
minification yes i
think everybody in this meeting
understands benefits we have a wolfram
language minifier
let me let me see what it does i mean so
you're just saying it's just removing
white space because it's zero area
just that because that doesn't maintain
semantics because you can't just remove
all white space
um you know that's nice i think it's
nice i mean that's
that's basically a zero airiness yes
yeah yeah i think it's nice i think it's
out of curiosity
is it also doing things that i mean
there are certain things that change the
structure of the expression but like in
like the one-liner competitions people
have done
like uh you know if you used a very
a function with a long name more than
once just you know
say yes or no it's very hard
your airiness de-errification yeah
i think it's nice i think that that's a
setting you know in the airiness
spectrum that's something
that should be set and i also suggest
that
in the function repository one has a
function called minify that just does
this
yeah yeah yeah i mean same same idea
right
okay um next
yeah i mean so these are all just kind
of like wrapping up items
um just wanting to show some community
interaction
um i've been making regular pushes up to
github of the parser and the linter
and i will be adding the formatter to
github soon you know after
so how do people actually use the linter
um so yeah i mean several users love it
i get feedback from shabbox
all the time but i want to know how do
you use it what do you do to to run it
what do you have to do how do i if i
want to run the linter how do i run it
so people run it on their code by
i know that brenton i'm asking how do
you set it up
right okay so you run code inspector
then what do you do
if there was a you know whatever file
you
you know you have some file laying
around and
you will get the same result as if you
gave it a string of code which i'm going
to just do
it's the same thing i just don't have
any files laying around right now um
okay and so what you see
this is maybe maybe more useful for
people um you know to get a summary
um you know to fix things and you know
the inspector has all sorts of options
to control
uh severity you know in all of this and
uh yeah i i yeah right
good i mean yeah i mean just to control
what
how pedantic and uh
you know what kind of checks are being
done what you want to see
so um yeah i mean a handful okay but so
so hold on hold on hold on
when we you know what is our plan what
is our roadmap for getting this into the
product
right so i mean the parser the lender
and the formatter
kind of formed this kind of triumvirate
in my mind
that i think we just flesh out we flesh
out the documentation
and yeah these are not promoted to
system symbols you know obviously for
12-2 but
they can exist in their own they could
be in the function repository couldn't
they
yeah like you were saying yeah yeah okay
i think they'll be excellent
um yeah i mean and then they live in
their own contexts and uh
people wait wait wait wait documentation
these are not these are self-documenting
creatures
there's no documentation that's going to
be terribly useful other than just
you know there needs to be the right
discovery interface for them but in the
end
you know there better not be
documentation this better be
self-documenting
your there better not be documentation
yeah it better be self-documenting it
better
i mean there should be a reference page
obviously very long
right right but i mean but but the way
people are going to call this
in the case of the package editor for
example there should presumably be a
button in the toolbar
that invokes this right that's another
yep i mean
yep okay
and in a standard notebook there would
be
i mean is this another right click type
thing
possibly this starts getting into the
original discussion months ago
about you know squiggly lines and how do
you mark up cells and things
and we're moving towards being able to
do you know get something like that
so well but but more to steven's point
what is the trigger that causes this to
happen
and i mean there's been some discussion
of like you know
trying to do stuff in the background or
something like that i'm i know that's
i'm worried about that yeah that's for
the future and i think
look i think for now why don't we try
and get this into the right click menu
as an experimental thing in the right
click menu yeah yeah well
but the question is you know so we do
like let's say we right click something
you know i have this whatever in a you
know
in an input cell and i right click and i
do something what i mean what's going to
be the result here
so so this is yeah i mean i mean
i think we kind of have a direction on
this
but uh but i'm not sure that we have
time to get the the thing that you know
steven that you would really like to see
in which is which is the the the thing
is basically once you've finished
there's an ok button so to speak inside
that box on out 13
and that ok button evaporates the lint
right well what we've been talking about
is is an inline lint right
you know i mean if if you're gonna do it
in a notebook you
you know you want the option to have you
know markings
in line that you can then uh expand
um yeah i know i agree yeah
uh and and i you know i have a basic
idea of how this is gonna work
you know what i uh the proposal we
discussed earlier was the one missing
piece that i didn't have and now that i
have that
but there is gonna be some
implementation time
and like i said 12-2 is not that far
away
fine well i mean for 12-2 i think having
this be a functional repository thing so
people can just do this
is fine i agree we're not going to get
the full
i i'm a little bit confused by
okay so you've got to me
let's say you have a gear menu on the in
the cell bracket for example
and or right click menu same difference
okay
and those cause a cell to be linted
yeah okay okay so now
some of that lintery i will dismiss
by virtue of saying that's a stupid lent
comment i'm just
ignoring it et cetera et cetera et
cetera i have a feeling that we will
want
well maybe we don't need this i mean
look once it's limited
it will be easy to dismiss categories of
things
um it will be not so easy
to uh to say um
you know in this instance right here
ignore this error message just this one
place in this one instance no no no no
no no
i agree i agree but to ignore an entire
category of
of uh linter warning for the cell
forever that's straightforward oh yeah
but but no
that's not the point i'm making the
point i'm making is as a
as a preliminary way of getting this in
what we want to do
like you're out 13 we say okay just turn
this input into this big linted mess
mess beautiful linted form which still
needs some design work because those
line one line two things are
unbelievably ugly
but in the case um what are you saying
that this exists then
i mean output right no i know i know i
know i know so i'm saying
you replace the input cell by this
and then you have a button in this that
says
go back delentify this get rid of all my
lint comments i just want to go back to
my original cell
replacing the input cell
if you trust your i know that's why you
guys
you're not ready for that that that's
that may very well be too ambitious for
12-2
no i agree i agree so that's why i'm
saying for 12-2
just put in but i think if if we wanted
to do that for 12 2 what we would do is
have it in a right click menu
replace the input cell with the linted
input cell and have
in the linted form here have a button
that says
delinch this
okay but it might be too ambitious yeah
um
and i need to run off here but um uh
let's see i just a few comments
on our live stream
uh ali on our live stream was was liking
the white on red
mathematica logo i thought we did have a
white on red logo
yeah it's i i he i i was showing 12-1 on
my system and i he was
i think seeing the 12-1 in my um
um well unless it was the prototype
build had a different one
um yeah it wasn't a prototype build um
okay question about the toolbar and
performance hits related to the
suggestions bar the toolbar is a
completely different story from the
suggestions bar
suggestions bar has to have to know i
mean we're keenly aware
of any potential performance problems
and
yeah i mean we use our product too we
don't want it slow
so bling bring back the old spiky
the how old yeah right how old we've got
a whole series of them
you can you can see the whole sequence
going back to the most prominent in fact
it was in that that i wrote that
blog post about the story of spikey um
that has the whole
elaborate story that leads us to the
jungles of brazil and places like that
yes that's that's that's
to get people to actually look at it to
find out how on earth that was connected
um okay um
um let's see question about code
obfuscation this is not really code
obfuscation this is not
true you know uh we have had various
separate projects on code obfuscation
which unfortunately don't go very far
because
our language has you know is a very open
language in many ways
and it's it's rather yeah
i mean true obfuscation is hard to come
by
yeah um question about
minification and the why we aren't just
sending things over in zipped form
we have much more efficient ways to send
things over than as plain text
like wwx files that's not what this is
about
um sounds good all right well this is
this seems to be coming along well so i
look forward to seeing it in some builds
coming soon right
yep and and some um uh
and yeah okay anything else yep that's
it
okay terrific thanks good work um
see all thanks to folks on the live
stream too see you later